Now look, here's the thing.
Last week, we did our first
Clueless Gamer in two years!
Whoa!
Yeah!
Not dog years, two human years.
(Sonja laughs)
Two years, it's mind-blowing.
Wild.
It was really weird and wild and fun.
It was really fun.
The game was "Biomutant,"
the celebrity was JB Smoove,
and it's so funny because,
like Sonja, you know,
we have been doing this
podcast now for quite a while.
But we haven't
done one since
we haven't done a Clueless Gamer
since we started this podcast
which is crazy to think about
(Sonja) Whoa!
Isn't that weird?
That is crazy to think about. (laughs)
(Aaron) And like.
Oh my gosh.
We did it at Largo in person
but I haven't seen Conan
in person for a year.
Oh my God.
But you know, we did
"Biomutant," which was the game
is super fun.
And you know, I mean, Clueless
Gamer, it's a comedy bit
you know. So I played, they
gave me the game beforehand,
and so, you know, I go through
with two of our writers,
Levi and Glenn, and we
wrote a bunch of jokes
and areas and stuff that
would be good for Conan.
And this was the kind
of perfect game because,
you know, it's easy to play
for him, which is good.
So he could actually
fight, which is great.
That is a huge achievement.
Huge achievement.
The world is great.
It's full of all these
like mutated animals
which is beautiful comedy gold, you know,
for like a comedy bit, it's perfect.
It's... it looks insane.
It looks great. It's gorgeous,
but it's a wild world.
It's so hard, you know,
when you do something
like a Call of Duty or
you do something like a,
you know, when we did Tomb Raider.
It's hard when it's like human beings
Right.
To make comedy
out of that, and we've done
so many of these comedy bits
that like.
But when
they're mutant animals.
Well, yeah, which is great.
A little more to pull from.
Yeah!
Any favorites?
Absolutely. I mean I think that.
And the great thing is
there was this moment where,
so there were these four
World Eaters in the game,
and they're these basically
they're giant boss fights.
And so we did a thing,
which is the Jumbo Puff
which is the first World
Eater you kinda come across.
Then we had them fight, and
as I was playing Jumbo Puff
for the first time,
it's great because you're
in this giant mech suit.
So that's great. A lot of
explosions and fun action,
which is great.
Very cool.
But then,
the, you know, there's
three kind of phases
to this boss battle.
And the third one is he eats you,
and you go down inside of him.
Oh my God.
And if you don't swim immediately to like
the esophagus wall, he poops you out.
Which is hilarious, you know,
And then he sits on you
and it's like, hilarious.
So right away, I knew we had
a great ender for the bit,
you know?
(Sonja laughs)
Ender?
'Cause that's the thing.
Well, it's (laughs) good one.
(Sonja laughs)
But that's always kind
of the thing, is like,
how do we get that? How
do we get the temperature
to a boiling point for the actual game?
So the, the comedy piece
has a good, good ending.
So I knew when I played
the Jumbo Puff, we were,
we were in good hands.
But.
I was gonna say that,
Jumbo Puff sounds delicious
but then everything
that you just said changed my mind.
(Aaron and Sonja laugh)
But it was great and JB Smoove,
aside from being just one
of the funniest people alive
and an amazing improviser,
also like, you know,
the great thing about
him is he plays games.
He's been in "Grand Theft
Auto," and he's actually.
So like these other
Clueless Gamers we've done
with like people like
Kumail or Ron Funches
who actually play games.
It just, it's so much easier
because he's just doing the things.
So it's not me being like, okay, go left.
Okay, do this.
(Sonja hums in agreement)
So that.
That, so JB was a real treat as well.
So we asked you guys to
send a few questions in
about the last Clueless Gamer,
and we've got a bunch here.
You ready?
Let's do it.
Alright.
So ChavChihiro,
I'm so sorry if I butchered that
but they asked, did clone,
did Clonan? (laughs)
Clonan?
(Sonja laughs)
That's Conan's clone, for
people who don't know.
Did Conan have much of a say
in the character creation
in the last Clueless
Gamer or was that all JB?
Well, it's interesting,
like again, I think like,
you know, we're making
like a piece of comedy
and to make that piece
of comedy I need to play
a lot of the game.
So I had to get far in the
game with a certain character.
So here's kind of a dirty secret just
for our podcast listeners.
They had fun talking about
the character creator,
which is, in "Biomutant,"
very robust and very fun,
but they had to pick the character
that I originally created.
(Sonja gasps)
So it matched later.
So it matched.
Uh-huh
So the footage matches. We
did that in "Skyrim" too.
I personally had played a Khajiit
who's like a cat.
Cat race.
In "Skyrim."
So when we were doing the
character creator part
in "Skyrim" as well. Jokes, jokes, jokes,
but then he needs to land
on a certain character.
So you're the man behind
the character creation.
The boy
In all.
I'm really a boy. I'm not really a man.
(laughs) You are the bouncing baby boy -
behind
the character creation.
Yeah. So they did their,
they do all their comedy
but then I did have to have them land on,
I think it was the Hyla character
'cause it was the toughest
because I knew Conan
would get beat up a lot.
So I chose that race.
(Sonja laughs)
That mutant.
I love these, I love
the behind the scenes.
Yeah. There we go.
I love the behind the scenes
Nolan Y. wants to know
are there any games that Conan
was surprisingly adept at?
No. Next question.
(Sonja laughs)
Not one?
Not a single, no?
He's terrible.
Oh, Okay. All right.
Even when we did "ARMS" with Will Arnett
which is all motion tracking
of him punching, he's still terrible.
It's, he can't do it.
(Sonja laughs)
It's, he's, you know?
Maybe one day.
Ashwin Shaji, again, I'm so
sorry if I butchered that,
but they would like to know favorite game
that Aaron has played with Conan.
I'm trying to think of the
one I got beat up the least.
(Sonja laughs)
The one where you've
endured the least abuse.
There was one where he
smashed three chairs on me
in succession. So that would be the least
favorite game.
That's your favorite. Oh.
No. I honestly, I think,
you know what I'll say?
The next one. I think like every,
every Clueless Gamer has
is fun in its own way
and is tough in another way.
But I think that.
This one was great, 'cause JB was great
and the game was fun, but.
But yeah, I think that's it.
And this was, this was great.
And I have to say like,
in terms of shooting
like in terms of us actually filming this.
Like Conan and JB are so
great together and the fact
that "Biomutant," like the
combat, you could just,
it's very kind of easy to pick up.
So that made it a fun
one to do with Conan.
Like people always want like,
oh, what about "Dark Souls?"
I'm like, it's just
gonna be Conan dying over
and over and over.
(Sonja laughs)
How can we make something
funny out of that?
But so this was, this was really great.
I love that. So you have fun.
You love, you're into "Biomutant."
It was really fun and I'm really happy
Clueless Gamer's back and.
Yeah, I'm excited to hopefully
get another one on the books.
Yes.
So I have a couple ideas
of ones that I think would be great
Ooh-lala
For another one
and if you guys have ideas, tweet at us
at @GoodGameNiceTry or
use the hashtag #GGNT
of games you think that would
be fun for a Clueless Gamer.
Obviously, we all think
"Resident Evil Village" would be fun.
So yes, of course. I would
love to try to do that one,
but other games I might not
know about or hear about.
Let us know.